um so i know you've been doing a lot of
speed dating today i'd like to throw in
at least one or two new questions
let's start with this one uh for each of
you
i'm curious if you remember your first
movie or tv show crush
oh aaron gray aaron gray uh
buck rogers that was my she was my first
uh
crush i think i think like when i was of
age to have an
actual crush uh it was definitely was
aaron gray
and then before that uh when i was a
younger kid i didn't understand why i
what was happening but i i i always
liked um eve plum
ah he plump yep but like in my formative
years
aaron gray i didn't see that coming
keegan
the eve plum you didn't see the plum
coming
um mine is very easy it's maxwell
caulfield from greece too
i felt i mean obviously
still my hair every day is a tribute to
him um
but yeah i like that was the first time
that i was like
i think i'm in love with a man um
god uh do you each have a tv series that
you would love to guest star on
uh yeah if i could yes i if if there was
a role
for me in the crown i would do it i
don't
think there is and i don't think i could
really nail that accent but like that's
one of those shows that like
you're watching you're like that's just
brilliant like i would do
anything on that show yeah
any show stephen any show yeah i pretty
much yeah
any [ __ ] um are you gonna go back
i was gonna go back like god i would
have loved to have played
um round about the fourth
season of the wire oh in the fourth see
the fourth season the schools this is
the fourth season is the schools like if
i could have played
one of those teachers beleaguered
teachers who's trying to help the kids
that would have been fun um other than
that it would be
it would be um you know yeah i would
like to
play one like a t that would have been a
wonderful like dramatic turn that's
something i would have dug doing that's
a really good one
that's a very jumping into why i get to
talk to you guys today uh andrew i'm
going to start with an individual
question for you
uh ryan gave you great roles in this and
boys in the band
what kind of thank you card do you
actually mail him
uh as a you know what i mean or what do
you get him as a gift
for giving you two great roles very
tricky
it's very tricky because he's a man who
has everything
um but the great thing about ryan is
that ryan also makes himself accessible
to you when you're working with him so
i um i have gushed to him
in person i have gushed to him via email
and
text um i uh
have regularly told him how grateful i
am to him for giving me these
opportunities so he um he's just uh
i don't know i just i i i met him sort
of
early on in my career and i i feel
um very grateful to have met him and
uh keegan and i have been talking a lot
about this today that
he's one of the few folks that i've met
in hollywood who
is actually they're actually like a
person of their word
um when he says he's gonna do something
he does it
um and it's really uh inspiring to get
to work with someone who is
has that kind of conviction and has a
clarity of vision about what he the
stories he wants to tell
and who he wants to be in them and um
i just i can't say enough good about
that guy
100 uh 100 uh keegan my individual
question for you is
so um obviously this this cast is
amazing uh
you had a number of scenes uh with
merrell which is
you know amazing um what did you
actually pay to be in the movie
i played i paid in bearer bonds so it
was
um you know it's such an amazing
experience
um to work with somebody that
accomplished
and and to see how
she works with such a human with such
humility
and which i guess i guess sometimes the
greatest that's what they do
there's a humility they sit under the
knowledge of of the story
and that's and she she does everything
she can to make the story
come to life and and i i'm just really
so much looking forward to seeing
to see how people respond to this this
piece of entertainment
because it's uh it's like rehearsals
like the the biggest sort of like you
know uh
thing that i was sort of floored by and
i was so nervous obviously to work with
merrill and nicole and like
walk into a set with them but they both
sort of dug in in a really sort of
cooperative
you know collaborative we're just part
of a company
and we rehearsed it like it was a
broadway musical so we had a very
traditional sort of rehearsal process
um but that's what i was so blown away
by by both of them was that they really
did just like want to do the work and i
don't know what i was expecting
but um it was really incredible to just
get to be
with them and just rehearsing and trying
things and
you know having some laughs like they
were they're both incredible
i already got to go had a million other
questions i'm just again going to say
you guys did such a great job
i know people are going to love it
thanks stephen thanks so much